[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur TVfil 78
édition spéciale du 78 C émissions CIN
thématiques à découvrir d'ici au 1er
janvier politique environnement sport
culture et ce soir économie bonsoir
Alice Gastine c'est avec vous que nous
parlons économie il y aura deux invités
pour nous accompagner ce soir oui tout à
fait il y aura Stéphane Kelian qui est
directeur marketing et communication de
one nation Paris au clés sous-bois c'est
un nouveau centre commercial qui est en
train de sortir de terre et Bertrand de
Cré qui est déjà en plateau avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes président du
meddef dans les ivelines et avant
d'évoquer notamment les négociations sur
l'emplois qui se sont tenus fin décembre
qui se sont soldés sur un échec le point
sur la situation à PSA Peugeot Citroën
un constructeur très implanté dans le
département oui 2012 année forte dans le
secteur de l'automobile notamment avec
le Mondial de l'auto qui a vu défiler
plus d'un200 000 visiteurs côté salariés
vous en parliez sur notre territoire PSA
a annoncé 8000 suppressions de postes la
mobilisation ne s'essouffle pas au pôle
tertièire de poissie peut-être qu'on
peut voir ces images voilà qui datent du
12 décembre mobilisation à l'appel de la
CGT qui remet donc en question le plan
de suppression des 8000 postes à PSA
voilà chez Renault aussi il y a eu des
grèves des débrayages qui ont rythmé
cette fin d'année regardez ce reportage
réalisé le 4 octobre dernier
avec le lancement de la nouvelle Renault
Clio 4 et de la Zoe la voiture
électrique de la marque le rendement de
l'usine de Flin augmente mais les
salariés sont confrontés à un manque
d'effectif selon les syndicats présents
aux portes du centre ce jeudi midi on
est en colère parce que il faut si on
veut fabriquer correctement des voitures
il faut du personnel et entre les gars
qui morflent sur les chaînes et cetera
d'un côté et ceux qui morfl du chômage à
côté bah c'est inadmissible et du coup
ça s'est exprimé vraiment par des arrêts
de travail ce matin pour contraindre la
direction à prendre l'effectif suffisant
encore ce matin il y a 1 he et de
d'arrêt de travail des caristes pour
réclamer du personnel supplémentaire
parce que il n'arrivve pas à décharger
les camions il n'arrivve pas à mettre
les pièce là où il faut et cetera et
cetera les salariés de Renault Flin se
rendront mardi 9 octobre pour manifester
au Mondial de l'automobile avant de se
joindre à un cortège national à l'appel
des syndicats
[Musique]
européens
notre première invité est donc Bertrand
Decré président du Medef dans les
Yvelines on attend donc votre réaction
sur la situation dans l'automobile le
département des Yvelines est le premier
département automobile de France il
représente beaucoup d'emplois entre
constructeur et sous-traitants et on le
voit beaucoup d'emplois sont menacés
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
ce marché inquiet inquiet inquiet triste
parce quand on voit une entreprises de
cette taille qui sont des entreprises
emblématiques arver à situation c'est
c'est c'est c'est inquiétant ce qui me
préoccupe alors j'ai pas la compétence
de vous dire pourquoi comment et ce
n'est pas de mon ressort euh par contre
en tant que que président de BF Vinois
j'ai j'ai une inquiétude et mon
inquiétude va sur les entreprises
sous-traitantes parce que c'est cl on a
parlé de salariés de Peugeot et c'est
très triste mais il y a aussi toutes les
entreprises qui qui collaborent à la PME
qui participent à cette à cette à cette
économie et là il est un peu tôt pour
mesurer l'impact mais j'ai quelques
craintes quand même à ce sujet et les
perspectives pour 2013 qui ne sont pas
bonnes puisque il y aurait 1 million de
voitures en moins d'immatriculé par
rapport à 2012 environ 11 millions
voitures immatriculées en 2013 ce sont
les prévisions fin décembre et malgré
l'appel de François Hollande a trouvé un
compromis historique sur la réforme du
marché du travail avant la fin de
l'année 2012 les partenaires sociaux
n'ont pas réussi à trouver un accord à
la fin du mois de décembre de nouveaux
rendez-vous sont prévus les 10 et 11
janvier objectif meilleure sécurisation
pour les salariés plus de flexibilité
pour les entreprises on évoque un
blocage plutôt du côté du meddeef qui
n'aurait pas en tout cas satisfait les
les les syndicats on peut évoquer
Bernard thbaau par exemple pour la CGT
qui a déclaré fin décembre le medf
voulait nous faire avaler une espèce
d'huile de rissin pour les fêtes de fin
d'année en révolutionnant le code du
travail facile facile c'est toujours t
euh et ça semble difficile de se mettre
d'accord en tout cas oui tout à fait
alors bon je permettez que j'ai je
manque un peu de recul sur le la fin
puisque l'formation est tombée ce matin
pour nous
euh aujourd'hui on on a quand même face
à nous des des partenaires dogmatiques
le medf a a fait des propositions des
propositions qui vont dans l'intérêt de
alors je dis bien de l'entreprise de
l'entreprise parce que c'est ça ne veut
pas dire forcément du salarié alors
contrairement à ce que à cela si si si
si parce que parce que quand on quand on
nous on s'accroche sur une flexibilité
clairire sur une une une baisse des
charges bon des salaires ça veut pas
dire moins de point d'achat pour le
salarié au contraire au contraire c'est
on a sécurité dans l'emploi peut-être
aussi mais la sécurité elle passe par
quoi la sécurité elle ne passe pas
l'emploi c'est pas une chose stable
c'est si une entreprise a besoin de
faire appel à des contrats à temps
partial si elle en a besoin c'est une
nécessité si demain elle meurt si demain
on en arrive à fermer l'usine et bien
tout le monde est perdant est ce qu'il
faut comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est un il faut desacord gagnant
gagnant c'est que l'entreprise à des
moments l'économie vous l' on l'a appris
subi des crises qui sont souvent
inattendues nos meilleurs spécialistes
en 2005 n'avaient pas prévu 2008 et et
on a eu à faire face à une crise
terrible mondiale qui est parti
d'ailleurs outre mer et il a fallu
réagir et à ce moment-là comment fait-on
alors on ne peut pas toujours maintenir
il faut savoir s'adapter la flexibilité
et l'adaptation seront une règle pour
demain pour tout le monde et dans dire
que les salariés vont devoir comprendre
que du jour au lendemain on peut leur
dire pour les besoins de l'entreprise
bah écoutez vous n'avez plus d'emploi
c'est pas aussi clair que ça c'est pas
ça parce que c'est ça dans l'esprit en
tout cas des syndicat dans l'esprit des
salariés aujourd'hui c'est ça
l'inquiétude principale aujourd'hui
c'est de se dire demain s'il y a des
accords des négociations et qu'elles
aboutissent à ça à ces réformes là qui
sont souhaitées en tout cas plus ou
moins par le MDF demain je pourrais
perdre mon emploi parce queon va
m'expliquer que pour l'entreprise c'est
mieux mais mais si demain on ferme
l'usine définitivement on perdra tous
les emplois donc c'est la solution moin
pire non non c'est la solution qui de
l'adaptation c'est passons une c'est en
fait c'est passons la crise et pendant
faisons un effort pendant une période
déterminé reprenons ensemble la
compétitivité ensemble trouvons les
moyens de la croissance gagnons et
l'emploi sera développé pour tout le
monde par contre le jour où on aura
fermé et que l'userine sera terminé ou
que la société sera morte et ben il y
aura plus d'emploi pour personne alors
malgré le blocage hein de ces
négociation François Hollande pense
pouvoir inverser la courbe du chômage
fin 2013 hein il l'a dit le 21 décembre
dernier sur Europe 1 le chômage
justement on en parle he Pôle Emploi
vient d'ouvrir un espace dédié au cadre
dans sa récente agence de Guille en
cours c'était fin octobre on regarde le
reportage réalisé par la rédaction à
cette
occasion les 2500 cadres en recherche
d'emploi du Sud Eveline ont désormais
une agence à leur écoute une antenne
Pôle Emploi dédiée à ce marché a ouvert
ses portes à guillancour un véritable
besoin 70 % des postes recherchés sur le
secteur ont un niveau supérieur au bac
le marché de l'emploi descad est un
marché assez spécifique qui est à la
fois très technique sur lequel on a
besoin d'une expertise pointue pour
travailler avec les les demandes emploi
cadre mais aussi avec les entreprises et
c'est aussi un marché qui est
relativement caché la plupart des
recrutements des CAD s'effectu par
cooptation réseau ou candidature
spontanée mais certains postes ne
trouvent pas preneur et souvent les
entreprises ignorent que PUL emploi peut
leur trouver des candidats cette
nouvelle agence permettra de renforcer
cette intervention auprès des
entreprises tout en multipliant les
opportunités pour les cadres premier
objectif c'est de venir en aide à ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin certains ont
ont un parcours atypique dans l'emploi
et n'ont jamais eu besoin de rechercher
un emploi se retrouve en position de
Senior de recherche d'emploi donc là en
fait on va adapter euh notre nos outils
à leurs besoins les 21 agents de
guillancour mettent en place des
ateliers CV y compris en anglais mais
aussi des ateliers vidéo pour apprendre
à se vendre et à convaincre lors d'un
entretien d'autres ateliers plus
spécifiques d'une durée de 6 mois
accompagnent les seniors de plus de 50
ans afin de pénétrer le marché de
l'emploi caché il y a une majorité de
seniors qui sont cadres et qui sont
inscrits dans les agences d'où la
nécessité de cette création pouvoir
faire une affectation et un ciblage des
besoins sur le secteur du Sud Evelin que
gère l'agence plus de 35 % des cadres en
recherche d'emploi sont des seniors
hautement qualifiés cette nouvelle
antenne vient renforcer celle de
Saint-Germain en laai également réservée
à l'emploi des cadres du
département mertand juste une réaction
par rapport au reportage qu'on vient de
voir sur cette agence spécialisée pour
les cadres pour Pôle emploi c'est c'est
une bonne chose déjà en tout cas c'est
une très bonne chose euh nous nous
travaillons bien sûr avec Paul emploi je
connais monsieur de grise et et c'est
une très bonne chose je ne peux que
saluer ce genre d'initiative dans cette
édition spéciale du 78 nous revenons sur
les grands dossiers de l'économie de
2012 ceux qui feront l'actualité aussi
en 2013 mais forcément je vais vous
demander de votre sentiment quel bilan
vous faites-vous en tant que président
du Medef dans le département et puis
chef d'entreprise également de cette
année 2012 ça a été finalement moins
pire que prévu écoutez j'aurais j'aurais
envie de vous le dire je voudrais faire
la part des choses entre les les grands
événements l'actualité nationale et
international qui qui n'est pas de mon
ressort et de ma compétence et plus
l'activité sur le département nous avons
la chance égoïstement en Yveline d'avoir
un un département qui est moins touché
où le taux de chômage est moins
important que la moyenne nationale et
som toutes mes adhérents sont inquiets
mais on épargn en parti voilà et on peut
dire que les affaires ne vont pas si mal
que ça euh vous savez le problème
aujourd'hui il est il est de tout sons
il est d'abord une inquiétude de chez
l'entreprise et et et le moral est
quelque chose de fondamental dans dans
l'entreprise parce que juste un petit
petit aparté là-dessus on vous parle de
Peugeot de enfin et cetera des grosses
entreprises mais mais la France est un
pays de PME je ne sais de le répéter et
et et les patrons français sont sont
d'anciens salariés qui ont créé
entreprise qui ont tout misé qui qui ont
une énergie colossale et qui créent de
de l'emploi qui créent leurs entreprises
euh quand ils n'ont pas le moral quand
ils ont plus confiance en l'avenir et
ben on peut avoir des risques de de
d'afléchissement de de cette croissance
enfin de de ce développement d'autres
choses l'autre fait marquant c'est la la
difficulté d'accession au crédit ça
c'est les banques on ont fermer un peu
les robinets et on sait que pour se
développer nous avons besoin d'argent ça
c'est l'autre inquiétude c'est l'autre
fait marquant de cette de de cette
période enfin c'était exactement
également vrai en 2011 euh il a un
dossier aussi peut-être c'est la
question de la CFE qui en 2012 a
beaucoup touché les PME et les TPE les
très petites entreprises oui la CFE
c'est cette cotisation foncière des
entreprises un impôt he qui depuis 2010
avec la cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée
des entreprises à remplacer la taxe
professionnelle alors il y a eu une
levée de bouclier hein de la part des
commerçants des chefs d'entreprise des
PME euh qu'il soit MDEF ou CGPME
d'ailleurs hein parce qu'il y a eu des
hausses enregistrées notamment sur
l'agglomération et puis le le le vote du
budget de l'agglomération a permis de
revoir les barêes donc peut-être P dire
un mot là-dessus parce
que tout d'abord le CFE elle touche
indifféremment les entreprises selon
leur taille et leur chiffre d'affaires
et le remplacement euh à cet effet je
dois saluer puisquon est on est sur
Saint-Quentin l'attitude de de la
communaé aglo de Saint-Quentin et
Monsieur
Cadalbert immédiatement quand ét informé
par nos adhérents nous nous sommes bien
sûr n rempli notre rôle et c'est notre
rôle voit sur ces images la mobilisation
des nous nous sommes allés rencontrer
les
élus qui ont écouté qui ont écouté et
qui ont réagi et et et je dois sal ce
bel exemple justement alors les les
fâcheux diront que c'est pas assez mais
c'està-dire que les tranches ont été
revues et Tran exactement exactement et
sous sous l'action du MDEF justement en
en discussion avec les élus il y a eu un
J visif qui a été fait alors certains
vous diront insuffisant n'empêche qu'il
faut faut quand même le saluer une toute
dernière question puisque nous sommes
pris par le temps sur cette édition
spéciale du 78 on parlera des centres
commerciaux dans dans quelques minutes
juste une dernière question quand vous
voyez partir des fortunes de France
alors on peut citer le cas de de de Part
Dieu qui a fait beaucoup parler ce n'est
pas un chef d'entreprise il y en a un
autre c'est le cas de Bernard Arnaud
pour LVMH qui souhaitait de obtenir la
nationalité belge c'est un peu compliqué
pour lui vous vous dites que c'est la
faute de l'État français la faute de la
politique actuellement alors c'est c'est
la faute de l'État et du climat et c'est
très triste et et et on peut le
regretter mais on le comprend quand
qu'en France une campagne dans laquelle
un candidat élection présidentielle dit
diabolise les patrons en disant il faut
leur prendre dans la poche un climat
dans lequel les patrons sont vilipandés
comme comme en fait les les les les les
les prédateurs de la société il est
compréhensible qu'à un certain moment
certains en est assez et même parmi les
alors on parle des gros je connais pas
monsieur ni Monsieur Arnaud ni monsieur
ni l'acteur de pardieu pas plus que cela
mais je vois autour de moi des patrons
qui sont qui ont créé leur entreprise
qui l'ont qui se sont batttu quiis et
qui pensent à partir mais ils se sont
pas d'abord ils le peuvent pas au début
mais ils le pensent il ils aimerent bien
parce que parce que mettez-vous à leur
place ces gensl ne sont au début jamais
rémunérés très peu mais quand on parle
de solidarité aujourd'hui même si c'est
un moment difficile à passer
c'estexplique le gouvernement ça sera
une
périe des hommes qui sont vilipandés des
hommes et des femmes qui sont vilipandés
à longueur de temps qui voient leurs
outils dépérir et qui sont toujours
taxés davantage et et toujours plus on
leur demande d'être solidaire mais à un
moment quand quand il travaille 80 heur
par semaine quand d'autres on travaill 3
5 qu'ils investissent leurs bien
personnels et qu'ils savent que au
moindre écart ils perdront tout qu'ils
n'auront droit aucune parle aussi
d'entrepris 40 par exemple entreprises
qui se portent très bien et qui mon
c'est 40 entreprises alors vous parlez
de 40 entreprises moi je vous parle des
millions d'autres entreprises je vous
parle du cœur de notre métier je vous
parle de ceux qui constiuitent la France
et ceux qui font l'emploi alors les
entreprises multinationales les k 40
c'est 40 oui dont acte mais les nôtres
nos PME avec les ceux qui sont mes
adhérents avec qui je discute mais mais
c'est justement cette manque de
confiance dont on parlait tout à l'heure
c'est c'est ce fait on ne peut pas
toujours sont des hommes et des femmes
qui sont non pas des des des des
héritiers de droit divin ils sont des
anciens salariés qui ont créé leurs
boîes qui ont créé leur entreprises qui
ont donné énormément et qui ont le
sentiment de ne plus être aimé
aujourd'hui en France c'est ce que vous
nous expliquez aujourd'hui merci Bertand
de créer d'être venu sur ce plateau le
78 édition spéciale économie va se
poursuivre Alice on va recevoir un autre
invité sur ce plateau juste la parole au
sainquantinois que vous souhaitez pour
2013 vos réponses juste Berton decé on
peut vous souhaiter quoi pour
moins de charge pour nos entreprises va
voir si les Contin partag cette ce
souhait pour l'année
prochaine bonne santé surtout la bonne
santé pour moi ser bonne santé déjà je
vais bien suis en bonne santé et je le
souhaite la même chose pour tout le
monde bonne santé la santé ça serait
bien enfin là on est vraiment on est en
fin de
course courage force et pu dans la vie
la santé le bonheur Mo domissre est
vraiment du travail pour je ben plein de
bonheur pour tout le monde ah que tout
aille mieux dans le monde bah qu' a plus
de solidarité surtout et qui moins de
chômage que la France a le mieux un
point de vue économique et tout ça VI
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens aussi
qui m'ont de fa les enfs qui m'ont de FA
et tout pour les aider aussi ça sera
bien
[Musique]
aussi bonsoir à Stéphan Celian vous êtes
directeur marketing et communication
d'un futur centre commercial au clés
sousbois que peut-on vous souhaitez pour
2013 bah beaucoup de succès alors nous
abordons à présent un enjeu important
sur notre territoire en 2013 les sort
des centres commerciaux on pourrait même
parler de batailles he tant il y en a
diverses mais certains s'affichent sur
les mêmes secteurs c'est le cas de one
nation Paris avec vous que vous
représentez qui est en train de sortir
de terre au clés sous boois le chantier
avance vite d'ailleurs face à vous Sky
West à Montini hein qui va se
transformer en futur donc carré privé
ouest et les responsables étaient
invités en plateau mais ont décliné
voilà l'invitation au dernier moment
donc vous VO la Seu en plateau pour
parler de ce projet alors pour commencer
parlez-nous du concept c'est de l'outlet
de luxe alors absolument c'est un outlet
de luxe un outlet finalement c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi un centre de marque
c'est un espace commercial où les où de
belles marques notamment des marques de
mode ou de luxe viennent proposer les
collections de l'année précédente et en
proposant les collections l'année
précédente ils offrent ils proposent un
discount une remise comprise entre 30
voire plus jusqu'à 70 % en période de
solde est-ce que ça marche est-ce que
estce que les gens n'ont pas envie
d'avoir la dernière collection quelle
est la mentalité de la clientèle c'est
un extraordinaire succès et nous on
pense que le le concept de l'outlet
Premium est promis un très bel un très
bel avenir un très fort développement
parce que finalement c'est c'est de
l'achat malin pas par excellence
et aujourd'hui on sait tous qu'on a très
envie d'accéder à des beaux produits et
que contenu notre pouvoir d'achat on est
obligé d'arbitrer un certain nombre de
de marques nombre de de dépenses et
c'est toujours très intéressant de
pouvoir proposer un produit dont la
marque est flatteuse qui est connu
reconnu en faisant une bonne affaire
est-ce que vous pouvez citer une ou deux
marques qui s'installeront est-ce que
beaucoup d'enseignes ont déjà signé
alors aujourd'hui nous nous allons
accueillir 140 marques grosso modo dans
dans dans moins d'un an on a dépassé le
le cap des 70 marques qui nous ont
rejointes alors c'est toujours très
compliqué de les citer non pas qu'on
qu'on a pas envie de le faire bien au
contraire mais c'est signé c'est acté
voilà c'est acté c'est sûr avec une
clause de confidentialité voà en fait
c'est les marques qui souhaitent garder
la maîtrise de leur communication bon
néanmoins on a eu l'occasion de vous
l'avez peut-être vu dans la presse
récemment de citer trois marques qui ont
elles accepté qu'on prenne la parole
pour elle c'est anesb j'imagine que vous
connaissez Luo qui est une marque
italienne qu'on trouve rue Saint-Honoré
par exemple à Paris et ailleurs et une
autre marque française qui s'appelle
American Vintage qui marseillaise qui
est une marque marseillaise absolument
ça semble vous faire plaisir surpr et
qui est présente par exemple dans le
quartier du Marais à Paris exactement
quel quel investissement a été
nécessaire pour déjà S un bâtiment de
terre parce que là par contre on
commençait de zéro et puis faire venir
ces enseignes alors le l'investissement
initial pour construire le bâtiment qui
fait 24000 m² sur deux niveaux c'est un
c'est un gros objet immobilier sans
doute un des des des principaux à naître
dans les mois qui viennent c'est 100
millions d'euros d'investissement au
norm environnemental aussi absolument
plutôt même très vertueux en terme
environnemental puisque ça sera le
premier bâtiment à énergie positive donc
l'énergie positive pour faire simple
c'est un un bâtiment qui produit plus
d'énergie qu'il n dépense consomme donc
c'est très vertueux c'est ça nous semble
indispensable en 2013 de pouvoir mettre
la barre très haut en terme
environnemental c'est une obligation
aussi beaucoup plus de normes
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant oui mais être
énergie positive n'est pas une
obligation mais c'est aussi un produit
d'appel c'est aussi pour donner une
image verte à ce bâtiment et faire venir
le c'est un supplément d'âme je pense je
pense que certaines marques sont
sensibles c'est pas obligatoire
néanmoins mais on a on a choisi de le
faire même si ça n coûte plus que de
simplement respecter les normes en
vigueur est-ce que c'est un plus par
rapport au concurrents également je ne
sais pas je pour se démarquer et faire
venir peut-être par exemple ces marques
qui seront toujours contentes de
communiquer sur cet aspect bâtiment
positif oui partiellement je crois
effectivement c'est pas fondamental je
pense c'est important peut-être ça sera
davantage sous la pression des visiteurs
des
consommateurs que simplement la demande
des marques nous avons intitulé cette
séquence centre commerciaux la bataille
s'engage vous le voyez affiché sur votre
écran est-ce que la bataille est
vraiment engagée est-ce que on est dans
un conflit ouvert avec avec les
différents centres commerciaux et
notamment Carr car alors caré privos
n'est pas là aujourd'hui c'est c'est
malheureusement on peut pas échanger de
mon point de vue je ne pense pas que
nous soyons vraiment sur le même niveau
que Carib pré West notre principal
concurrent il est pas dans les ivelines
il est à l'autre dans l'autre côté de
Paris il est à Marne la Vallée qui
s'appelle La Vallée Village qui est
installé depuis une dizaine d'années qui
est un outlet premium comme nous on le
sera également sur un traitement
architectural très différent mais
peut-être on pourra y revenir et
finalement nos concurren c'est plutôt la
Vallée Village mais plus loin c'est
aussi les ventes privées qu'on trouve
sur Internet qui connaissent un fort
succès ce sont les soldes qu'on peut
trouver dans les grands magasins voyez
le périmètre de concurrence finalement
il n'est pas forcément sur des gens qui
font ou prétendent faire la même chose
que nous mais plus largement sur toutes
les offres finalement d'achat malin qui
peuvent être disponies voilà pour
repréciser les chos en fait Sky West
qu'on voyait à l'antenne deviendra carré
privé wouest pour fin 2013 l'ouverture
aujourd'hui est prévue fin 2013 le
bâtiment existe déjà contrairement à
votre projet l'idée c'est de tout
refaire et d'attirer aussi de l' halè de
luxe donc on est quand même sur le même
créneau euh théoriquement oui le modèle
de l'outlet de luxe a besoin de quelque
chose que nous on va avoir c'est
l'ouverture le dimanche l' le dimanche
c'est jusqu'à 30 % du chiffre d'affaires
réalisé par les marques et carry privé
wouest je je connais pas moi la date ré
d'ouverture nous on est ouvert le
dimanche avec une autorisation en rèle
ça fait forcément beaucoup débatat temp
il suffit finalement de se rendre sur la
zone de clé sousbois le dimanche pour
constater que les Decathlon que alpha
par Castorama sont ouverts le
dimanchecoup de magasins aussi qui sont
ouverts mais qui préfèrent aussi payer
des amendes et sans pour autant avoir
les autorisation en fait le le la zone
de plaisir est dans ce qu'on appelle le
puce qui est un périmètre urbain de
consommation exceptionnelle qui nous
permet l'ouverture de dimanche et c'est
parce que on peut être ouvert le
dimanche que on a choisi ce
terrainl mais non parce que c'est c'est
c'est consubstantiel de l'économie de
l'outlet l'ouver sur le dimanche et les
marques qui nous reviennent aujourd'hui
ell le placent quasiment en argument
numéro 1 vous avez mentionné alpark
justement il y a beaucoup de centres
commerciaux he sur le secteur qui sont
pas forcément sur le même secteur que
vous le même registre que vous mais il y
en a beaucoup alphaark voilà par exemple
est-ce que c'est saturé actuellement la
zone selon vous il y a quand même
beaucoup de centres commerciaux qui
s'ouvrent vous mentionnez la zone de
plaisir
énorm forme de coignè un petit peu plus
loin de de 50 an alors la zone de
plaisir c'est 20 millions de visiteurs
par an c'est une zone qui est
extrêmement populaire dynamique et
depuis des années donc nous on va se
servir de ça pour avoir un trafic qui
est déjà existant et que qu'on va de
manière plus aisée que si on devait
s'installer au milieu de nulle part et
créer du trafic maintenant one nation
Paris n'est absolument pas comparable à
des centres commerciaux traditionnels ou
à ce qu'on appelle des retail park comme
alpha Park c'est vraiment un modèle très
particulier totalement unique si vous
voulez le le monde du commerce il
connait une profonde mutation la la la
galerie marchande avec un hypermarché et
des magasins ça suscite finalement de
moins en moins d'adhésion parce que
c'est un modèle qui a vécu il faut se
réinventer l'outlet premium donc une
très belle variété de marques avec des
très bonnes affaires financières et dans
un environnement qui est flatteur qui
est qui est très moderne très
contemporain ça c'est une recette
gagnante alors on voit à l'image les
images de d'Alpha Park 2 c'est
l'extension d'Alpha Park qui a été
inaugurée en septembre avec le plus
grand mur végétal d'Europe on parler
d'écologie se tourner vers
l'environnement pour attirer plus de
clientèle c'est aussi l'option qu'a mise
alphaark 2 on regarde ce
reportage 75 millions d'euros
d'investissement pour réaliser ce centre
commercial tourné vers l'écologie c'est
10 % de plus que pour une version
classique et 15 ans d'amortissement
nécessaire avec le plus grand mur
végétal du monde des jardins et un
parking vert l'extension d'alphaark 1
aux clés sous-bois mise sur une
clientèle familiale l'immobilier
commercial pendant des années c'était
des des des boîtes à chaussures en
bardage pourriis qui défiguraient les
entrées de ville nous avons nous décidé
de de de d'investir dans le
développement durable nous avons décidé
d'investir dans la qualité car nous
pensons que les clients à l'époque du
commerce élect onique vont continuer à
venir dans des centres commerciaux mais
dans lequel ils vont trouver un plaisir
qui un plaisir de se promener un plaisir
d'aller faire du loisir une aire de
pique-nique des restaurants et des
activités de bowling et de karting sont
proposé face à une concurrence féroce le
choix du développement durable et du
loisir s'est imposé il faut savoir
innover en permanence pour apporter au
clients bah ce qu'il souhaitent ou ce
qu' ce qu'il ne sait pas encore qu'il
souhaite en fait les premiers clients
étaient attendus mercredi matin
accueillis par des salar recruté le plus
souvent localement au total 700 emplois
avec le la la première phase de
d'alphaark qui sont qui ont été destiné
en priorité bien sûr au au cléiens
puisque donc nous avons même organisé
des recrutements à l'intérieur de la
ville tout près d'ici un autre centre
commercial est en train de sortir de
terre positionné sur l'outl de luxe il
devrait permettre la création d'une
centaine
d'emplois une centaine on avait vu un
peu petit hein finalement ce sera autour
de 800 emplois rapidement quel est le
calendrier pour One nation Paris alors
deux dates à retenir la livraison des
boutiques aux marques qui nous
rejoignent c'est en juin 2013 et
l'ouverture au grand public sera à
l'automne 2013 vraisemablement en
octobre prochain et la crise ne vous
fait pas peur au contraire je pense que
la crise elle appelle de ce type de
d'initiative commerciale je pense que
c'est une très bonne fenêtre de tir et
on verra si vous avez ou non raison au
cours de cette année 2013 c'est la fin
de cette édition spécial du 78 consacré
aux événements qui ont marqué 2012 et
puis ceux qui vous attendent 2013
également en matière économque merci
Alice je vous retrouve ainsi que
l'ensemble de la rédaction dès le 2
janvier en direct à 18h avec de nouveaux
invités toutes nos éditions spécial de
cette fin d'année sont à retrouver aussi
sur notre site internet excellente
[Musique]
soirée